Hi.
Whoops!
*Laughs*
-That looks hilarious.
-That didn't work out too well!
Hi.
My name is Markiplier.
And I'm currently - Ahh f-
Again. Hi.
My name is Markiplier
*Laughs* fucking-
*more giggling*
No imma do it, I- I can do It, I just need to do it smoothly. Right? That's the only thing
Hi!
My name is Markiplier and
Currently- that's not smooth
It's- mhmmmm mhm!
If you want to see exactly when and where we're gonna be and see our amazing show that we have in store for you
Just go to tour.markiplier.com
Fu- haha! *more laughter*
Euahh hang on *giggling*
*murmers* Alright
pffff *breathy boi*
Very cas... Is that cas?
Amy: Yeah you look cas
Is that cas? Does it look cas?
Amy: It looks kinda cas
Alright, hang on here.
Hi
My name is Markiplier and currently- I'm out touring with my friends in Europe. We're going all over the-
European- *stutter* fuck! *more giggly Mark*
I-it's just I slide! I can't- I can't not slide!
Hi
My name is Markiplier, and we're currently on-
Amy: *laughter* Let's post this fully unedited
Mark: Shh! Nooo *giggles*
Hi
My name is Markiplier, and I'm currently touring in Europe right now with my friends
*more giggling* Ow!
Hi
My name is Markiplier and currently I'm touring all across Europe with all of my friends
If you want to see when and where you can see us live and in person in our highly rated and highly recommended show
*breath*
Just go Tour.markiplier.com and see for yourself. It's full of fun
It's full of laughs and there's some emotional moments too. So check it out. Don't miss out, and we'll see you in Europe
*slurp*
*deep sigh*